c'est devenu claude mégo lemay est
souvent monté sur la scène du théâtre st
denis en 1988 seulement il y a joué avec
céline dion à 42 reprises du premier
jour aux derniers jours
son conte de fées avec céline dion a
duré 28 ans et il s'est terminé de façon
abrupte en 2015 quand son contrat n'a
pas été renouvelé
quand ça s'est arrêté j'ai même arrêté
de jouer du piano ont beaucoup après mon
renvoi relaxe hélène j'ai pris ça dur
puis il faut que je consulte parce que
j'ai besoin des deux
et ça passe a pas marché ça n'a pas
fonctionné avec joie au lieu de
consulter un autre psychologue mégots a
décidé de faire le deuil en se confiant
au journaliste frédéric arnould qui a
écrit sa biographie sa règle et mai
prochain livre ça à régler toute la
tristesse que j'ai eus quinquin céline
marouani
lui qui est contre la légalisation de la
marijuana raconte dans son livre qu'à
ses débuts il en fut mais beaucoup on
croyait que ça aidait la créativité
par contre quand on se met à écouter ce
qu'on aurait fait la veille on
s'apercevrait bien que c'est un
postulant castle mais c'était quand même
ça faisait partie de l'époque
dans sa biographie mégots parle aussi de
ses collaborations avec entre autres
claude dubois et jean guy moreau et ils
voient ce livre comme un cadeau pour ses
enfants il en a eu trois au total est il
un rêve qu'il estime très réalisable
vous savez que ce qu'on veut on peut oui
moi je crois en son rêve devenir le
pianiste des rolling stones
rien de moins ici louis philippe ouimet
radio canada montréal